CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
OPENING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
>> POLITICO OUT WITH
EXPLOSIVE REPORT ABOUT
POTENTIAL DEEP STATE SPYING
ON A FORMER TOP TRUMP
ADVISOR.
HERE IS THE HEADLINE.
FBI SURVEILLANCE OF CARTER
PAGE MIGHT HAVE PICKED UP
BANNON.
NOW, ACCORDING TO THE
REPORTING, CARTER PAGE WAS
BEING SURVEILLED BY THE FBI
LAST JANUARY DURING THE
PRESIDENTIAL TRANSITION WHEN
PAGE HAD A PHONE CALL ABOUT
RUSSIA WITH FORMER WHITE
HOUSE CHIEF STRATEGIST STEVE
BANNON.
REVELATION DURING
CONGRESSIONAL TESTIMONY AND
PAGE SAID AT THE TIME THAT
BANNON CALLED HIM ABOUT
CANCELING A PLANNED
TELEVISION APPEARANCE AND
THEN PAGE EVENTUALLY BROUGHT
UP THE PHONY DOSSIER WHICH
BUZZFEED HAD PUBLISHED JUST
A DAY EARLIER ON
JANUARY 10TH.
NOW, IT'S NOT CERTAIN IF THE
CONVERSATION WITH BANNON WAS
PICKED UP BY THE FBI, BUT
NATIONAL SECURITY EXPERTS,
THEY'RE TELLING POLITICO
THAT IT'S VERY POSSIBLE THAT
IT DID HAPPEN.
NOW, INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER
SHARYL ATTKISSON WHO SAID
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION YOU
MAY REMEMBER, MADE.
OFFICIALS AND I WAS TOLD
THIS BY INSIDERS HAS
SOMETIMES BEEN USING BAD
COURT OTHER PEOPLE THAT ARE
THE TRUE TARGETS THAT THEY
CAN'T GET A WARRANT AGAINST
BUT TO WRAP THEM UP IN
INCIDENTAL TARGETING.
>> Sean: WOW, THIS IS BEYOND
SHOCKING AND RAISING VERY
ALREADY KNOW.
NOW, ACCORDING TO TWO
REPUBLICAN MEMOS, THE FBI
LIED TO THE FISA COURT.
REMEMBER?
THEY USED A CLINTON BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN DOSSIER
THEY NEVER VERIFIED OR
CORROBORATED IT IN ORDER TO
NOW, REMEMBER, THE GRASSLEY
GRAHAM MEMO, THAT DETAILED
PUT TOGETHER BECAUSE HE
THOUGHT WELL, THE FORMER
THAT THEY NEVER VERIFIED.
THEY ALSO KNOW THAT COMEY
SALACIOUS AND UNVERIFIED
BEFORE.
AND THE DOSSIER WAS GOOD
BUT IT WAS UNVERIFIED AND
SALACIOUS?
THIS ENTIRE SCANDAL NOW
WREAKS OF CORRUPTION BEYOND
SEEING HERE IS THE POWERFUL
TOOLS THAT WE GIVE OUR
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY TO
PROTECT US ABUSE TO SPY ON
OPPOSITION CAMPAIGN.
DURING AN ELECTION AND
NOW, ALSO TONIGHT, FOX NEWS
HAS OBTAINED HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN DEVIN NUNES' LETTER
HEARINGS.
ASKING FOR, QUOTE, ANY
RELEVANT FISA COURT HEARINGS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE INITIAL
APPLICATION OR SUBSEQUENT
RENEWALS RELATED TO
ELECTRONIC SURVEILLANCE OF
CARTER PAGE.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THEM
TOO.
THE HOUSE COMMITTEE IS
SETTING A FEBRUARY 16TH
DEADLINE THAT'S ONE WEEK
FROM TONIGHT FOR THE COURT
TO PROVIDE THOSE TRANSCRIPTS
IF THEY IN FACT HAVE THEM.
GETTING THESE TRANSCRIPTS
WOULD BE A MASSIVE
WE KNOW THE TOP ECHELON OF
THE FBI AGAIN THEY RYE LIED
PAID FOR DOSSIER TO GET THAT
WARRANT.
AND THEN, OF COURSE, ON
CARTER PAGE AND THEY DIDN'T
TELL THE FISA COURT THAT THE
DOSSIER WAS, IN FACT, BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR WITH ABOUT
SAME LAW FIRM.
THIS IS KEY IN ALL OF THIS.
HOW COULD YOU USE AN
UNVERIFIED RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA DOSSIER TO GET A
FISA WARRANT TO SPY ON
OPPOSITION CANDIDATE AND AN
INCOMING PRESIDENT?
ALL RIGHT, ALSO, OTHER
BREAKING NEWS THIS HOUR.
ANOTHER NEW EXPLOSIVE
REPORT, ACCORDING TO ABC
NEWS, SENATE INVESTIGATORS
THEY ARE EXAMINING A SECOND
ANTI-TRUMP DOSSIER.
NOW, THIS WAS PUT TOGETHER
BY LONG-TIME CLINTON ALLY,
GUY BY THAT THE NAME OF CODY
SHEARER.
ACCORDING TO ABC THE SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE IS
NOW TRYING TO SET UP AN
HE PUT TOGETHER THE SECOND
DOSSIER AS, QUOTE, AN
INDEPENDENT JOURNALIST.
BECAUSE, ACCORDING TO THE
GUARDIAN SHEARER HAS TIES
GOING ALL THE WAY BACK TO
WHEN BILL CLINTON WAS
PRESIDENT IN THE 1990S.
WE DID REACH OUT TO SHEARER
FOR COMMENT.
SHOCKING HE DIDN'T GET BACK
TO US.
WE ARE ALSO LEARNING TONIGHT
THAT THE STATE DEPARTMENT
WAS IN FACT INVOLVED IN
OBTAINING AND THEN SPREADING
PHONY ANTI-TRUMP INFORMATION
DURING THE CAMPAIGN.
REALLY?
AND A FORMER TOP RANKING
OFFICIAL AT THE DEPARTMENT
THAT HILLARY CLINTON USED TO
RUN IS ADMITTING IN A "THE
WASHINGTON POST" OP-ED THAT
HE WAS IN CONTACT WITH
AND THAT CLINTON CONFIDANTE.
ROSENTHAL GAVE HIM
INFORMATION.
CODY SHEARER WHO WE JUST
TOLD YOU ABOUT.
STRIKING FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT BECAUSE REMEMBER,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE USED THE
INFORMATION IT WAS NEVER
VERIFIED, CLINTON PAID FOR
AND THEN IT'S USED AS A
BASIS FOR A FISA WARRANT.
YOU GOT THIS GUY JONATHAN,
SENATORS GRASSLEY AND GRAHAM
EXPOSED EARLIER THIS WEEK
WHEN WE GOT THE UNREDACTED
VERSION.
AND, OF COURSE, WE HAVE
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES,
WELL, HE TOLD US IN AN
INTERVIEW EARLIER THIS WEEK
THAT HIS COMMITTEE IS NOW
INVESTIGATING THE STATE
NOW, IN AN OP-ED ENTITLED
DEVIN NUNES IS INVESTIGATING
ME, HERE'S THE TRUTH.
WELL, WINNER
WELL WWINNER
WELL W WNNER
WELL W WINER
WELL W WINIER SAYS HE MET TO
AFTER WISH WINER TALKS ABOUT
THE DOSSIER I WAS ALLOWED TO
REVIEW ABOUT YOU BUT NOT
KEEP THE COPIES ENABLED ME
TO PREPARE THE STATE
DEPARTMENT.
I PREPARED A TWO-PAGE SUM
RIL AND SHARED IT WITH NEW
LAND WHO INDICATED LIKE ME
SHE FELT THE SECRETARY OF
STATE NEEDED TO BE AWARE OF
THIS MATERIAL.
FORMER OBAMA SECRETARY OF
STATE JOHN KERRY MAY ALSO BE
INVOLVED IN THIS SCANDAL.
KNEW IT AND IF HE EVER SAW
THIS DOSSIER, WHAT HE KNEW
ABOUT THE DOSSIER.
HE ADMITS HE, TALKING ABOUT
BLUMENTHAL, SHOWED ME NOTES
GATHERED BY A JOURNALIST I
DIDN'T KNOW, CODY SHEARER
THAT ALLEGE THE RUSSIANS HAD
COMPROMISING INFORMATION ON
TRUMP OF A SEXUAL AND
FINANCIAL NATURE.
AND WHAT STRUCK ME WAS HOW
SOME OF THESE MATERIALS
ECHOED STEELE'S BUT APPEARED
TO INVOLVE DIFFERENT
WRITE ON MY OWN I SHARED A
COPY OF THESE NOTES WITH
MEANT BY THAT AND HE SAID
INFORMATION HE HAD GATHERED
FROM HIS SOURCES.
BY THE WAY, RUSSIAN SOURCES.
THEN HE WRITES I AGREE TO
LET HIM KEEP A COPY THE
SHEARER NOTES.
WINER GOES ON TO SAY
CHRISTOPHER STEELE SHARED
THE INFORMATION THAT HE GAVE
HIM TO THE FBI.
DO YOU SEE HOW UNBELIEVABLE
THIS IS?
WE REACHED OUT TO BLUMENTHAL
REQUEST.
SO THIS WHOLE SCANDAL STARTS
PRIMARY AGAINST BERNIE
SANDERS.
WHY BERNIE PEOPLE AREN'T
MORE MAD, I DON'T KNOW.
THEN SHE TRIED TO RIG THE
GENERAL ELECTION AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP.
SHE PAYS FOR A PHONY RUSSIAN
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DOSSIER,
THEY DON'T TELL THE FISA
JUDGE THE TRUTH TO GO OUT
AND GET A WARRANT TO SPY ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN BEFORE
THE ELECTION AND THEN THEY
HAVE BEEN CAUGHT UP IN
BY THE WAY WE ARE LEARNING
IN ADDITION TO THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN, WHILE WE HAVE
HILLARY'S ALLIES, THEY ARE
FEEDING ANTI-TRUMP DIRT TO
THE STATE DEPARTMENT, WHICH
IS SHARING IT WITH
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
LIKE WE HAVE BEEN TELLING
RIGHT NOW, I PROMISE YOU
IT'S GOING TO ONLY GET
WORSE.
WHAT WE HAVE NOW IS A SLIVER
OF THE INFORMATION.
IT'S COMING OUT DAY BY DAY.
I HAVE BEEN WARNING YOU FROM